-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden visited
an Amtrak maintenance facility
today in Delaware.
So we got an extra hour
of sleep this weekend,
but he sure didn't.
"I'm too excited."
Former President Trump
took the witness stand today
in his civil fraud trial.
He swore to tell the truth,
the whole truth and nothing
but the truth,
and then everyone
just laughed and laughed.
While testifying during his
civil fraud trial today,
former President Trump said
that he believes
his Mar a Lago resort
is worth between
$1 billion and $1.5 billion.
Oh. Very smart.
The insanity defense.
Dude, you bought it
for $10,000,000 in 1985,
and now it's worth 1.5 billion?
The only way I would believe
that is if it was in Brooklyn.
Then that's about right.
Maybe a little low.
While testifying today,
former President Trump
also appeared to forget
that he wasn't president
in 2021.
Well, so did half the country.
After FBI agents raided the home
of his chief fundraiser
last week,
New York Mayor Eric Adams said,
quote,
"Where there's smoke,
there's not always fire."
Ah, yes,
that famous expression.
Okay, so we found out
he's shady.
But you know what they say --
late is worse than never.
The third Republican
presidential primary debate
will be held Wednesday in Miami
or, as it's now dubbed,
"Who Wants to Be
a Vice President?"
Pennsylvania Senator
John Fetterman
criticized California Governor
Gavin Newsom over the weekend
and said he was secretly
running for president,
as opposed to Fetterman,
who looks like
he's running for
guy who doesn't wipe down
the equipment at the gym.
Meta CEO Mark Zuckerberg
revealed on Friday
that he tore his ACL
while training
for a competitive MMA fight.
Apparently,
what happened was
there was a coffee table
in the way.
The fastest runner in
the New York City Marathon
yesterday
finished the course
in just under two hours
and five minutes,
a full ten minutes faster
than if he had taken the bus.
Better luck next year, the bus.
Archeologists in Germany believe
they've discovered
the ancient remains
of a husband and wife
buried in the same casket.
Her idea.
[ Laughter ]
Baz!
We're going to win them back
with this one.
And finally, the American
Ornithological -- Ornith--
Oh, Jesus.
I said this word wrong
last week,
and I got a lot of angry notes
from ornithologists.
And now I'm in my head about it.
And finally, the American
Bird People Society
announced --
It's fine.
It's an either/or.
It's famously an either/or.
Announced last week that it
is renaming birds
that are currently named
after problematic people,
though in retrospect,
it was never really fair
to name that one
Jared from Subway.
And... that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're up and running.